the yankees will get a look at jose
barrios tonight start number 32 on the
season for jose last time out that was
versus former team six very good innings
really just a bad three batter stretch
for him in that game where he gave up
those three runs and that cost him lost
that game three to one but he's working
on a streak right now six straight
outings with at least six innings
pitched he's everything the blue jays
had hoped for when they traded for him
they need another big one from him
tonight
down and away
on three pitches
here's anthony rizzo change up
[Applause]
that has come on for him i think over
the last few years so a great start for
barrios now he will face aaron judge who
homered last night his 37th of the
season
what a start for jose mourinhos
and garrett cole a nice even 30 on game
started this year and the rest of the
numbers are really good across the board
let's check out the pitcher scout report
brought to you by kia and really it's
state your case time i mean there's
really a two-person race for the cy
young this year in the american lake
it's him and robbie ray and tonight
could go a long way blue jays are
probably playing for their life tonight
as far as any kind of play-off options
so you know they came out swinging
semi-a tied for a major league record 43
home runs for a second basement there it
is deep drive out to left field marcus
simeon two run home run a major league
record for marcus simeon no second
baseman in the history of the game has
hit more home runs in a single season
than marcus simeon
what a start for the blue jays tonight
up two to nothing already
montoya is going to do the honors with
that
record-setting home run right there from
marcus simeone boy did he ever turn on
that fastball
two-nothing toronto and threatening
again in the second now here is springer
so we get a hard ground ball past the
dive of the mayhew into left field
espionage turns the corner he will score
it's three-nothing toronto in the second
inning that's what you want to see from
that lead-off spot that experience
slowed the ball game down he doubled his
first time up and scored this time to
try to sneak the fastball by him once
again and george is all over it
lines it past lemay who can't come up
with the circus play at third base
espinol third run of the game already
for the blue jays three doubles a single
in a home run they've all been hit
extremely hard boy they have rattled
garrett cole's cage a little bit here in
the early going haven't they here's boba
buchet beau doubled into the right field
corner on the first pitch he saw from
coal in the first inning there's a swing
a long fly ball out to center field
gardner races back gets to the wall
turns around it's out of here
the blue jays second homer of the night
he doesn't get cheated
number 27 for boba shet rbi number 100
and it is four to nothing way to join
the club the 100 rbi club marcus simeon
did it early with a home run beau's
going to do it with number 27. what a
swing to get to that high fastball and
drive it the other way well as we start
the fifth inning
is pitching a perfect game 12 up 12 down
curveball got him to chase
strikeout number six for burrills and
joey gala was the battle with fly ball
to center
got another one gallo unhappy that is
seven for barrios two down in the fifth
here's gleber torres
the pitch is lined there's a base it
over third that ends the no hitter
torres will round first head towards
second he'll be there easily with a
double so gleber taurus breaks up the
perfect game by hitting a bullet over
the bag at third for a double uh here's
arshella yankees it down by four
hit on the ground toward the middle and
through to centerfield up base in torres
will score and the yankees get on the
board
a two-out ribby single by giorshela
and toronto's lead is now 4-1 so here's
gardner with a runner at first a run in
and two outs driven into right center
field hernandez can't get there it's
gonna bounce up against the wall or
sheller rounding third he's coming home
he'll score it's an rbi double for
gardner and now the blue jays lead four
to two and the yankees have cut it in
half brett gardner in the bottom of the
order
coming through 16th double 37th rbi for
the veteran george springer leading it
off springer doubled and scored in the
first singled in a run in the second
bringer swings at the 1-0
and he pops it up near the line it left
gallow going back with herschela and
nobody takes command
springer ends up at second
it's a three-hit night for george
springer and what a gift on a fly ball
to left field near the line
calls of mvp cascading down over
vladimir guerrero jr
down the line springer into score rbi
double it is five to two now the yankees
if they get a a ground ball or fly ball
can make it 5-3 judge this one to right
hernandez there tagging from third le
mayhew
and they get the run back that they gave
to the blue jays
rbi for aaron judge on the sac fly it's
5-3
now the tag runs are in scoring position
but with two out saw sanchez with a bat
they're staying with higashiyoku
higashiyoka into left field how about
kyle higashiyoka he knocks in both gallo
and torres and it's five five
five five ball game as the blue jays
back in the eighth here's bo bushette
there's a swing at a high fly ball out
to straight away center field laid back
at the track gets to the wall it's out
of here
it's gone bo bushet with his second
homer of the night
and the blue jays are back on top 23
years old first full season to the major
leagues let's not forget and what a
moment for beau bechet blue jays with a
6-5 lead hit on the ground diving stop
it short by o'shella throws from the
ground in time for the out what a play
sit on his backside and get up he threw
the ball lying on the ground and threw
it perfectly to roost the blue jays
leading six to five time run at second
romano kicks and deals bringing a fly
ball out to center sinking quickly
here comes springer he's there to make
the catch and finish the ball game they
get a win they absolutely had to have
[Applause]